thank you malavika and appreciate
welcome everybody to our meeting of the
risk and Assurance
um committee thank you for all being
here
um I just wonder we could have a quick
look at the apologies I we've received
the late one from Tom
um uh dramatically he's had a tree on
top of his car the poor man so when he
does get in not to our meeting but I
think later in the day have a bit of
sympathy for him but he said he's at the
end of a chainsaw right at the moment so
um uh let's uh concerning for him so
Tom's an apology if you have anybody
else
move
secondly sorry so we're fine so we can
move I'll move from the chair all right
you're moving now you're Darren thank
you and Leslie thank you I'll put the
motion all those paper please say aye
aye those against us caring are there
any matters coming up that people need
to acknowledge interests
it's not that's great look at the um two
sets of minutes we've firstly got the
meeting of the 20th of December last
year
um uh which uh we have in front of us
um I'll move from the cheer we accept
them as a true and correct record are
there any matters people think you
roasted any matters if people need to
note
I think they looked like them there was
actually one minor change malavika
um just on uh item sorry uh
propagate update on the annual report
um
I just think we've got a little sentence
here where we say
um uh during the meeting on the 24th
20th of
24 November 22 with the order director I
think we better identify who he is
and in the following sentence we say he
was told
noting nothing for it is nothing
thank you it's actually quite important
context worthwhile raising here
okay with that I'll put the motion all
those paper please say aye all those
against us carry similarly we've got the
7th of March our meeting earlier in the
months
um smoother and sick sorry
do we have a move in a second of uh
let's please thank you Darren thank you
obviously are there any comments on this
um there was only one action item which
I'll just a quick deal with which was
the summary annual report that has not
been cleared and Patricia is trying to
chase her on that one so by the end of
the week hopefully by the end of the
week that was something you delegated to
me
uh to clear and we're still doing that
so we'll set the No No additions or
changes or Corrections being none I'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
aye those against us carried very much
got a move to the internal audit and
continuous Improvement update welcome
Peter
um
in your hands Salient points and then
we'll move to uh discussion uh just
comment around uh recommendation too
a potential postponement of a couple of
the reviews I'll request that the
relevant GM answer any uh comments right
questions on that additionally we are
waiting for two final reports to come
through regarding our rates processing
and
um
contract compliance uh review that was
requested from the infrastructure
operations manager and they'll go
through reported it with July risk and
insurance committee meeting
very good thanks Peter only got
questions for Peter or indeed
um the GMS that are assembled here thank
you for being here by the way
yes Ross
just in terms of the payroll just going
back uh what's the French benefit tax
issue finally resolved yes and it's
sitting with the voluntary disclosure to
ird sitting with them in the present
that would be most effective I presume
the deferral of the major infrastructure
project management review makes sense to
you yeah absolutely it was at my room
oh okay oh okay in that case it was nice
before you start doing it so in fact
what's comforting
um uh is that actually there is existing
work that is doing that is working on
that rather than necessarily needing to
uh defer and leave a gap in our work so
that's fine
um complaints and oh sorry Grant you've
got a question sir yeah just with
respect to payroll what the human
component of that
note that um you know pay advice comes
out very late
obviously someone's you know working
late to do that how well resourced in
that area in terms of
um
that are in relative to health and
safety those sorts of things um we're
managing it
we are looking at
resources and systems at the moment
so it is one that we're managing and
trying to manage that restrict that over
time and late we're talking five o'clock
or six o'clock
yeah no later
yeah so secondary in terms of that then
when will those resources be in place to
alleviate those pressures that you're
managing well it's uh it'll be within
the next six to eight months wrong
thank you
yes Lobby oh
ringy sorry I'll take that as well I do
that all the time don't I I do that all
the time and I owe everybody's apology
probably in advance sorry about that
buddy
um look just just since we're talking
about payroll uh um our elected members
supposed to get payslips
we do no no I'm just asking that because
obviously I don't but so that's why you
do check your email no no I'm saying
that I have checked my emails and I
don't get any
so I'm just wondering is that something
we should get yes okay
no that's cool that's your three emails
uh yeah that's my that's what I expect
the ICC payroll to come too uh will be
whatever email address that you have
requested that they go to when you're a
first sit at home assistant
yeah well I've only got I would presume
for a different person because you all
have an ICC
um uh email address which I think it
would be relevant to go to I think there
shouldn't be any option because we
should be quite concerned about our yes
okay our business we know too many
stories of uh yeah priority mail
addresses around the place so um I
suspect should all be to the people's
ICC addresses so obviously I need to
talk to someone about that I will raise
it with the 10. yeah cool so look what
we're doing with payroll Peter or
somebody can I do some pets to Patricia
um we seem to have more issues and yet
I've got a report here saying it's well
controlled
um which sounds like a good news story
so rather than trying to snatch um the
feet from the jaws of Victory
um I just wonder Patricia um are you
able to use a sense of a tenor of any of
the recommendations can I say I think
probably in the future and we do get the
summaries which I'm quite happy with it
would be good to understand the
recommendations what what was the nature
of the recommendation um the
recommendations were further automation
which the team were already doing we
still had a proliferation of manual
timesheets for staff around the
organization they have been moved on to
or on to a less paper-based timesheet
we do have a lot of variable workers
within our Workforce so that's at the
pool in the library which come with
their own payroll complications and
issues and we're working through those
ones in the team have a very good manner
of dealing with that
um that was the really the only one
which we're already addressing
um other than documentation in fact this
is the first internal audit report where
I've seen that they suggested we do too
many checks
okay well that's good so we are looking
at trying to get that right balance of
um
checking versus the time it takes to do
those additional checks
thanks for that update
we've got some outstanding
recommendations there Peter are you
comfortable with the clearance rate on
those uh yes the uh
the main ones relate to having the
credit card policy in place
which is work in progress and a cash
handling policy so once those two
policies that'll clear up most of those
from the sensitive expenditure in the
cash handling pretty cash reviews
I must confess my eye went to the table
above which was things like the Building
Services
in the building Administration where
there were still some outstandings there
thinking about Building Services
presumably bco et cetera it's just
concerned about progress on that we had
meeting regarding those yesterday and
morning chair and we are progressing
those as just prioritizing the workload
with the resources we have right okay
good we're not running any undue risks
no no okay bring it thank you any other
questions for for Peter or the team
symbol here
there being none do I have um this is
the note the the recommendations we
receive the report
um importantly we res we approve the
postponement of those two matters as
discussed and that we note the
these the DCC the Deloitte ICC payroll
review going to move in a second thank
you Leslie thank you grant
um any discussion on the motion
what are all those in favor please say
aye
aye those against
Carrie
under the goodness check we don't have
any member of the committee on the
screen doing by bunnycast no no okay I
just I'm always conscious so I tend to
forget apart from also for getting your
name ringing I tend to forget people
that are actually on the screen so um
it's great
right health and safe health safety and
wellbeing update Peter yes so I'll be
interested to see how it's going
um the only comment I have here cheers
that this will be the final time I
present this report we have our health
and safety manager in place we'll be
reporting this going forward brilliant
and did I see a second position as well
also in the process of being a point a
bit yes we have a health and safety
coordinator who is going to be an
internal appointee and they start job
sharing shortly until they simply take
up the role in April brilliant oh that's
that's good news Well Peter thank you
you've owned the brunt of having to
deal with this Force so thank you for
your work today I know I presume there's
other stuff that you're happily engaged
in so thank you for your work here in
terms of getting this to us and welcome
to the table also Andrew our cro I
learned the other day what that meant so
um uh
um so look great to have you here too
Andrew and and look if I can just say to
the committee my depreciation also to
Andrew who have you just assumed this
role I think is that right Andrew
uh I assume being put into that role yes
[Laughter]
well thank you Andrew already if I can
just reflect the committee since Andrew
has picked up a role of cro Chief
response he's been very active in
talking with me and so I'm thrilled with
actually and I think we're seeing gonna
start seeing this with the events that
are occurring for the committee it's
Andrew it's great to have you on board
anyway key thing in front of us at this
stage health is health safety and
well-being Andrew was there any other
comments apart from impedance that you
wanted to add to this before I open up
the conversation
I'm happy to wait and see if there's any
questions I'd like to think the report
should prompt some questions but if they
don't I'm happy to
comments some areas where you might want
to have a look right okay
um folk questions for Andrew or Peter or
indeed anybody else
yes rangi
um look I just want to go to the the
graph uh it's on page three
um regarding
um
employees and third-party contractors uh
first aid administered near misses Etc
now
for six months that's what period is
we've got over 30 near misses for
employees and for contractors just just
shy of 30 near misses now
like an EMS as as do we get any more
detail on what a near Miss may be
because obviously if you go a couple of
pages on there's a risk chart and it
tells you how
to deal with perceived risks and
identify risks and one of them says try
and find another process because this is
obviously too dangerous now what do you
do with near misses
there's an investigation
but would we get to know what they are
like uh dropping a chainsaw and missing
your foot or is it more like a paper cat
or so if I could jump in their chair I
think the the key point and we're trying
to draw out in this report is that if it
was a seriously in this point of a
better description and under the
workplace health and safety act there's
some near misses themselves that
depending on how they occur actually
reportable if we think a near Miss is
providing a suggestion that we're
operating outside our risk appetite then
we will graze that to you and raising
explanations to why and what we're going
to do about it if it's a near-miss which
I should say there's a paper cut or
something like that we'll do an
investigation make some improvements but
if we don't think it's showing an
underlying problem with our risk
management we wouldn't necessarily
escalate the details of yourself
obviously interview questions
it just leaves me pondering about those
30 odd near misses and and and just
actually what they are and do I need to
worry about them or not
at the moment I'd say worry about the
ones that are requiring first aid and
accept that the new misses are not
moving your current risk
position further than the actual
incidents are but potentially those 30
odd Nemesis could have been the ones
requiring quit State no they're separate
no but call Dave if they actually
occurred agreed yeah if the near Miss
had been not an EMS but an actual
accident and that would shift that 30
across into the other column
and I'm just just it doesn't sit well
with me that then I'm sitting here a bit
blind on
on these things happening you know it
makes me worry the fact they get
reported means they're serious enough to
get reported
um and but we're not we're not seeing
any more information on them
and yeah and I suppose all I can say is
that we'll escalate to you if if they're
of a nature where we think they need
escalation and that will be around where
it causes us to operate outside your
risk appetite
which is what we're calling out here on
the actual
treatments
yeah no it's just foreign to me when I I
mean the company I ran we
um we did a lot of Contracting work and
and near misses were unacceptable it
just wasn't you something was it was a
reason for the nemes and and uh yeah the
tolerance for near misses was extremely
low
so obviously we that's yeah no no it's
just a matter of getting the tolerance
understood
thank you chair okay I've got um uh
Grant uh then Darren then Ross and then
knobby
thanks to you just I'm referencing that
conversation so it is the escalation
process you've said officials will raise
it to this committee if that concern as
they're outlined in this paper or the
criteria for it so that's in our risk
management framework so there's a
criteria for why you're always
collecting how you escort if we're
outside your risk appetite yeah we will
tell you if we think the business is
operating outside the risk appetite new
set we will tell you hence why this
paper says we think you're operating
outside your rescapital but was
specifically related to Nemesis oh
anything it should be you're comfortable
that there's a robust process around
escalation I I wouldn't say to you I'm
100 comfortable on the investigation
near misses which is why I say to you in
this paper
focus on the ones we know there was an
adverse outcome of course that puts you
outside your tolerance can I say to you
categorically that the knee misses are
all with intolerance
no but we're operating outside our risk
appetite because of the actual events
that have occurred and Emissions are
important don't get me wrong and but
don't focus on the new misses when
you've actually got adverse outcomes
occurring
because that tells you something's wrong
the near me says when we investigate
them they could be underlying causes
but they're not necessarily going to
shift it as far as an actual event
occurring yeah but the nature of health
and safety around culture is that the
less near-misses you have the more worst
incidents you will likely have I mean
that's that's proven through a number of
case studies around health and safety
monitoring and management
I don't want to get into a theoretical
debate but well it's not serious to the
point you actually want depends on your
definition of an emisse so for us then
misses include things where nothing
occurred so having records all over the
floor is argued to be a new Miss because
it's a breach of our
a great approach
doesn't mean anything's occurred we want
people to tell us where we're acting
where things no matter how remote could
be wrong so look at me
says oh
inside the secondary Point
um which was the one I had written down
was just around this report
um my question is is the right
information being reported and
what I sense from this is its outcome
Focus not prevention focused
and you'll see that come up in the next
paper around where we're at in terms of
our maturity
um so I agree with you I mean and and
to be blunt with you this report's come
up every month saying the same stats and
no one's asked a question
um we need to start changing our Focus
to looking at what are the treatments
we're putting in place to preventing
these things to occur rather than
accepting a report with Statistics which
just go through to a keeper so so with
that
I mean whose responsibility is there
okay well for us in terms of overseeing
that governance absolutely but
what I think of her just say is that you
know
you're obligating the responsibility of
managing risk to this committee when in
my view that should be done by the
officers
I think Grant you raise a very good
question I'm happy to pursue it but I
think we've got that coming up in the
next paper okay okay yep because
actually we've got we've gotten the next
paper the advice from PR law which is uh
well standing advice to us plus a plus a
report and I think that might be quite a
valuable place to have that discussion
I've got some questions about that
report too I understand that but we
aren't quite there but all I'm saying is
can you just hold on to your question
yeah yeah
so I think we've got ourselves too is is
your point um Andrew that actually uh um
this is a standard report that we've
received and I directed or not reacted
to over the course of it but you've also
highlighting and signaling that the next
paper is perhaps a key question around
maturity which could have an effect on
this report going forward
right I've got uh Darren then I think my
order right thanks chair just a quick
comment around near misses and that I
disagree with the comments made by the
councilors I think I'd be more concerned
about a culture where they weren't being
reported because it shows a lack of
vigilance
um you don't want a situation where the
potential for an EMS occurs absolutely
but the fact that somebody has
identified it and ensured that it didn't
become an actual risk or incident is is
positive if you were having none of that
if there were no near misses then there
is no vigilance
so can I just reply to that so I'm not
suggesting for one minute that we
shouldn't be reporting new misses
what I'm suggesting is that
you know what it shows in oh you're
pacing your health and safety is that if
you have less near misses in an
organization so it's not so don't report
them and say absolutely report them but
focus on a culture that prevents near
misses because then you
are more likely to have less
serious incidents
thank you Darren is anything else you
want to do no Ross
the part I see missing from the reports
of well-being part and
around EGP usage or any of the start
mental health yeah and I'll acknowledge
and I was actually going to make a
comment around that clearly missing
well-being and I think it's fair to say
I mean is it post covered is it because
of covert who knows I don't really want
to try and put any blame on Covert I
think gets blamed for enough but there
is uh I think a clear indication coming
from staff as much as anything else that
they want more of a focus on well-being
and I think that elt is recognized that
and is doing more in that space and so
I'd expect it will start to put more of
that in this report because I think it
is you could argue that it's picked up
in the other bits but it's not really so
we'll have a bit of a separate Focus
around that and have a look at how we
can do some work in that space
Alexander Lobby
um yeah I've got a whole raft of issues
on this report so I'm just going to work
my way through
um being mindful I've got that
background and health safety so on page
19 where it says background
I think the opening statement there is
misleading I think uh Grant's already
touched on this Council has specifically
delegated to the risk Insurance
committee responsibility for health and
safety well actually our job is not
responsibility for health and safety is
responsible we are responsible to
monitor that the staff are doing their
job
more generally the committee has
responsibility for organization risk and
management again all that buck stops
with the chief executive that's what the
x is now slight difference when we get
further onto the next paper when it
starts talking about the legal opinion
from PR law
where it talks about the Local
Government Act and how that interacts
with the health and safety and
Employment Act but I can tell you that
the latter overrides The Local
Government Act and that's General
principal rights throughout law in New
Zealand if you have a specific act that
overrides more generalized comments and
and and other acts so that statement's
there is not quite right for me
um
when it gets down on the next page to
page 20 it talks about due diligence
visits
and the purpose of these due diligent
visits which I assume are group managers
going to different areas is to in part
to better understand how health and
safety risk is being managed
in a case and of course that's all very
well because this paper talks very much
about a framework
but the bottom line is the act requires
some stuff other than Frameworks it
requires in very simple terms you need
to identify where risks are
and then you have a series of options
that flow from that risk and I've been
here I guess now nearly four years or
300 bit I have yet to see any report
that tells me about
um
about the near misses they're both rangi
and Grant have raised and that worries
me and it worries me I hear a statement
today with that sort of safe from Star
um look if you don't have any
near-misses you've got to worry
well no that doesn't need to be the case
if you don't have many near misses it
might mean that you're actually doing
the job really well which is identifying
the risks
once you've got the wrist you then are
required to
remove the risk if you can't that can't
be practically done then you've got
other options around training staff
mitigating the risk
um and so on and provide protective
equipment
so if the ACT is very simple when it
steps through that I don't see us I see
us coming from
quite a wide range of papers over the
last four years
step us through this sort of discussion
but at the front end I don't think we're
just they were doing Our obligation and
I've said this before and I'll say it
again if we had a serious exit now what
we don't have in place would get us into
trouble with work uh work safe in New
Zealand we're horribly Exposed on this
because we're very reliant on the
toolkits whatever they are so the the
downside of a toolkit is that you have
people in a particular area who do
regular checking of their own ears
that's a flawed process because you
become familiar with your own place
so one will pass this report on page
24 board books talks about there's been
a completed Civic administration
building workstation review done well I
can tell you from my background there
are major issues on this in this
building uh health and safety issues
that are not identified in that report
and that's a worry
because if people are going to do it are
not skilled in
in the area of before I would say
Environmental Lighting
um around ergonomics around workstation
design
and how people fit in there so it's too
easy to have I guess lay people in
health and safety doing this work
pleased that we've got some new staff
coming I think that's great because they
will probably bring some expertise in
that area but I still have some worries
about that on page 21
I don't know why why actually means on
the graph something might be able to
help me with that but it does say
reported
since September 2023 I don't think we're
quite there yet
so that must be a typing error
I presume means 2022.
um on page 22 of board books there are
six paragraphs there
and I defy anybody in around this room
to tell me what those six paragraphs
they came in I'll read it three or four
times and I'm really struggle what we're
trying to say in that report so anybody
else looking in on it certainly staff
looking you know would be really
confused about what all that's about
um and at the very end on page 24 it
talks about
um
regular audits being undertaken as as
the next steps which I agree order so
really really important but they need to
be physical audits not
system or system orders which is very
much the framework in which we're going
to operate
but do we actually have in place people
who go into an area who don't
necessarily work in that area that have
some expertise
can look around and pick up things so
problem sake it's no good I don't know
it's no good if you're sitting in here
and you're the general manager of
finance or something sorry Patricia if
I'm picking on you
um and you go down and go into a pump
station you will not see the technical
stuff that you need to see there
and the safe and use it the safety
report that we got last year identified
that that they went down there was
somebody had a machine was working in a
pump area but had an isolated piece of
Machinery you know that's a near Miss
and that has serious potential if you're
working on a machine that's meant to be
isolated but it's not but that was
picked up by the outside set of eyes not
picked up by the people working there
because they get familiar with their
workplace
and so familiarity uh increases the
liberal risk
so I guess that's that's my bet uh the
overall
um
report is very much a system one and I
think we've got some pieces of our
customer safety missing
um and certainly the the terminology
means needs to be that we are here to
make sure the organization is safe and
to monitor staff's activity in that area
but the buck needs to stop with the
chief executive that's what the
legislation settings doesn't stop with
us as as uh Governors and our reports
should say that because at the moment
when I read that report it implies that
this committee is actually responsible
for health and safety
thank you City comments Michael or
Andrew would like to make to that at the
stage I think the next paper again
um Lobby your Comics prefer as well the
discussion we need to have with the next
paper
anything with us at
right I wonder if I could um ask my
question and
um obvious well if I can say Andrew you
caught my attention by saying that we're
outside our risk
uh tolerance
and I
um wanted to really just explore that
with you if I could
um I take it from the discussion that
we're outside France given the nature
sorry given the number and presumably
the nature of the actual events that are
occurring so in other words
you're signaling to us from a management
perspective we have too many accidents
and it is taking us outside what we
count as our risk appetite around health
and safety right that's great brilliant
thank you I tend to think in terms of
preventing the teeth controls and and I
mean we've got some Boutique controls
here and it's saying that actually our
prevention isn't working
can I ask what is Management's response
when we're living outside our risk
tolerance
because I can say I'm not happy it's not
the right business the question is is
there an is there a risk is there a an
equal and opposite management response
to being outside Aristotle the short
answer is yes and I supposed to flag
that in the recommendations I mean I
would have liked an Ideal World to be
here today telling you exactly what
we're going to do
um but I think the next paper really
looks at how we're going to do it and
that will identify what we need to do as
much as anything else because at the
moment
um to your point and what the paper is
trying to say I can't tell you whether
it's a lack of control uh like all
people following controls or some other
event that's really causing those
incidents at this time
um and obviously depending on which one
of those thread is will require a
different response from management
what I can and do preface in the next
paper is that I think clearly there's a
cultural question I think that reflects
really some of the issues that have been
raised here
um yes it's not this committee's role to
be down in Management's job in doing it
but it is this committee's role to hold
management to account
and where that is not occurring is a
cultural problem as much as any other
cultural problem
um and so there's the cultural piece to
me has to be the starting point
um we have to look at
that across the board I mean and in the
broad sense it's a weak question it's
not a management or a governor question
or a staff question it's a it's a wee
question and that's what I'm really
flagging at this stage and once we get
an answer to some of those questions
we will come back to the next meeting
with a plan to bring us back with
intolerance because that must be what
the objective is either that or you
change your your appetite which I can't
imagine I change it to where we're
sitting that's
um that's really helpful
um so actually you know I think despite
the criticism that's come out about the
report
um can I say I think achieved your aim
which is Bruce this is kept coming and
nobody's made a comment well we are now
you've got us activated
um but I think
um nobby's comments certainly reflect
the seriousness with which what you're
highlighting here for us which actually
makes the next paper really really
important but the critical thing about
this and I think this needs to be seen
by the whole Council is the assessment
and I've got no reason to not believe
it's right
is that we are outside what we have set
ourselves as our tolerance for health
and safety and it's a very serious
situation I got Grant I'm sorry I've got
Navi and then
just a follow-up to your question chair
um which is not for Andrew to comment I
guess but just on what you were saying
um certainly from the X perspective
which is a health and safety Employment
Act
um nowhere does it talk about tolerance
for risk
it talks about identifying risks and
once you identify risk your first step
is to remove it
the second step is if it's not practical
to remove it and that can be you
physically can't do the work without
that risk or alternatively the cost of
removing it and replacing something else
that's two horrenders you then have
another series of options to work your
way through so it if we have a serious
accident keep saying this
we cannot defend ourselves by saying it
was within or without our tolerance of
risk because there just words that mean
nothing absolutely nothing the
requirement from the ACT is is specific
to each and every risk you can't class
them together and say well we've got a
mild a mild tolerance for risk safer I'm
taking this building because there are
some serious risks on this building but
we just don't know they're there if you
do that you get lost in a much wider
picture we need to somewhere along the
line start narrowing this down to
specific workplaces where we go out and
do specific risk identification and then
make the decision do we remove the risk
or do we then subsequently leave it
there and manage it which is what the
second part of that process is and how
do we train staff to be aware of the
army going mentioned at that risk so
they're not putting themselves at risk
as well look I don't doubt your advice
nobody actually think we're all agreeing
pretty strongly on the same point
there's value in recognizing the health
and safety from a organizational
perspective is a strategic risk I think
there's also
you're going to use the risk too many
times as a chance that we're also
talking past each other around the word
risk which is which is one thing under a
under a risk management framework versus
a hazardous in terms of the act so um
they have to be Blended Grant you've got
your comment too yeah just
um
so I'm clear and I'm interested in some
comic from other councilors or yourself
chair so what we're saying is we've
identified that we're outside but we're
going to wait till May 23 uh the 23rd of
May two months
to receive a plan of action around how
we move back within that risk is that
acceptable
well that's that's the advice we've
received um so it's really a question of
whether the committee is happy with them
what is possible in practical in the
time
Michael Mike here to comment on that but
I'll apparently you've got a
relationship I just don't agree I mean
after growth you may in regards to the
workstation stops episode
um probably some of the key things like
well-being is absent
um but I also
I say for me what triggered me was
really around the contractors
and how and I was really looking at the
medical treatment and looking at the
Matrix and looking at the moderate too
severe type category
and how that was all being managed
I mean
when when you have like third party or
contractors on site I mean
those risks should be actually addressed
yeah by the organizations themselves
yeah
so I'm just really just wanting to know
a bit more about that
I suppose through each year
let me I suppose quote the comment I say
internally 80 of our work is done
through contractors
I mean contractors is one of our biggest
risks and and that's what you're seeing
there
um
I agree with you and then it's something
that we need to look at but that that is
we
where where one of our biggest risks in
these spices and I think the key thing
is
that contractors are just workers and
we've got to get that through our head
um I think we sometimes don't recognize
our responsibility for contractors
thank you um I'm just wondering if there
anymore I ever since the next paper is
really important because it's got the
foundational points that ultimately uh
go back to novice questions Grant it
goes back to your question is is
ultimately what is resolution five here
which is about a May 23 report
um uh uh and and
um it's almost like on reflection it
might have been good to hear the
previous paper first
um uh but
um what I am wondering is if in fact we
should hold the set of resolutions over
until we've had a conversation on the
next paper how would the committee feel
about that because effectively we're
blending the two where it's difficult to
answer all questions on this paper
without also opening what is clearly the
main event which is the next paper yes
Navi
um so I just want to go back to what uh
Grant said before because I think it's
really important
um leaving it till May is an okay thing
you can't do health and safety risk
assessment without having people on the
ground that know what they're doing so
we've got people coming you can't wave a
magic wand and do it tomorrow so our
biggest risk to date is that we haven't
done that
so if we have an accident the next two
months we've got a tail out the window I
guess the other thing is I don't think
anywhere in any of this stuff we should
have the word risk appetite because that
implies that you have a degree of
appetite for risk now in the accounting
world and they're counting an audit
world you know that yet we have a risk
appetite for certain types of processing
that if we check every single little
piece it would be so overwhelming that
we it wouldn't justify the action so we
have an appetite to say checking not
checking certain accounts that are under
20 or whatever but in health and safety
there is no wording around risk appetite
if you identify the risks and you deal
with them one of two ways remove or deal
with them and you don't have a defense
anywhere if you have a bad accident to
say well you know we've got a a medium
risk appetite in the Parks and reserves
or a low risk appetite here that doesn't
cut it and say we've got some serious
work to do but we need the people to do
it which is what Andrew's saying before
we've got people coming
just be aware that we have an exposure
in the intro yeah
right yeah so
what I'm would like to see is is just a
bullet point action plan so we've
identified here okay so what so we're
gonna
recruit some staff to go and do an
inspection you know the selections we
can do between now and 23 that
demonstrate to
that this committee takes seriously the
fact that it's been raised that we're
outside at risk
profile or whatever you want to call it
and this is what we're going to do in
the interim until we get to the May 23 I
just don't think it's
acceptable that we sit here and say oh
we'll just May 23 will solve their
problems hopefully we've got to have
some action points around okay so what's
going to happen and it could be just a
half page it just documents the process
between Nelnet because that shows that
we have acknowledged that we're outside
it and we're taking immediate action to
get to where we need to around her
isn't that what broadly I mean short of
the the half page isn't that what these
recommendations are acknowledging right
well I hope so I mean management is
saying we're outside we're outside a
generalized sense of of risk tolerance
and in fact something has to happen and
they are developing and taking action on
on those you know your your six points
so I don't think I don't I presume we're
not doing Ashland's double negative I
presume we are doing something positive
in the next two months around health and
safety other than just just having a
ride you know what assumption needs to
and and the and the point would be so so
how would we know that well I'm inviting
management to telegram that's what I
that's why I've said perhaps Michael
might have a comment that he'd like to
make okay sorry sorry if I can start
with this let's just let's just know
that's what's happening in the intro
absolutely through yourself chair we do
have a work plan that we're working
through
um the update report does highlight on
on it it doesn't go through the specific
details in in that particular update but
we do have a more detailed work plan
that we are working through as an
organization
um
we are flowing through a whole new
culture in relation to that we put in
the steps of all of our governance
boards Etc from so we've got the
reporting going through and we are
taking a stock take of all of the
hazards and risks across the
organization as part of the first steps
within those those boards to make sure
that we have the full listing from that
perspective so we have that in play and
that is happening within that two-month
time frame so it's it's kind of
indicated in the next report but it's
not it's not in that detailed bullet
point stage that's being requested I
have noted that down or something we can
go back and look at and bring forward to
um committee going forward
right I think I've got knobby then
running yeah sorry and I'm pretty
certain I've named them the right order
yeah the right way round yeah just in
relation to what Michael said
um again there are risks involved with
that that process model
um so one of the risks is that um while
you're identifying the risks at the
moment we don't have independent sets of
eyes doing that I'm not convinced that
GM's going into other areas that they
don't have responsibility is the way to
go the staff you're recruiting is the
way to go they'll bring some specialized
knowledge but they'll bring some info
some knowledge gaps as well and I would
I would expect that the organization
once they get those players in place
will then prioritize which workplaces in
order of priority that they would go and
visit to do that identification work
because in the interim having other
people look who don't know the area
there's a real issue and a classic
example is this building
causing major issues thank you I think
Mike would like to respond today yeah
thank you through yourself chair and
then I'll ask
Steve gippling to provide a response as
well I just want to
highlight that the GM visits are not
in place to try and do a full review of
those processes they are on and above
they are they are there to actually go
and do an independent assessment of
different areas uh in
all the GMS have been through training
to actually undertake those they are not
there to go and do that detail site
inspections I'll hand over to Steve
because we are going through a process
in relation to those inspections thank
you Steve yeah thank you um the chief
Executives probably answered or provided
what I was going to say
um and it is we are bordering on the
next paper as well because it does talk
about the officer's functions and and
our offices due diligence requirements
we aren't doing detailed assessments but
we are seeing that work is done as
workers we expect it to be done and our
job as officers under the actors to
satisfy ourselves that there is evidence
to see that those Hazard plans exist and
that staff understand what the risks are
in their workplace and can describe it
to us as Leaders so that we get a sense
of how their culture is and so
um yeah I think it doesn't replace the
technical role that the mayor has
identified and and we're grateful that
we've now been able to recruit into that
space But we still have obligations
under the ACT
thank you I think just one comment on
that
little blessing um
if you look at the cases that end up in
in the court through worksafe New
Zealand they all fall into one of two
areas
one mainly in one or two years one
there hasn't been an independent set of
eyes across the wrist that's the first
thing
and the second thing is that that online
managers have seen practices that are
not good and have turned a blind eye to
it so you know you've got a guy that
constantly doesn't work he's hard out
and then he has an accident and and what
comes out is it he hasn't worn it for
the last year and everybody's just
ignored it so the other the two risks
that we'll face going forward
it's two major ones right runy
look up follow up on something Grant
commented on and that's the use of the
the word uh risk appetite for health and
safety I don't I don't think it should
be in there it came up in a workshop
recently on our appetite right across
the board and for me
um
you need to be compliant with work save
when it comes to these things and that's
that's the rules you can play with and
counsel as a group of elected members
should not be in a position to set a
grade of risk appetite for such a thing
I mean we need
and I was baffled at their previous
Workshop why we started debating it
considering when we look at the next
paper
um you know you just
health and safety near misses I've just
been online looking at the near misses
that work so prosecute boom near mess
prosecuted you know nothing happened but
it was a near Miss ninety thousand
dollar fine so
um that's who we live up to and and as
an elected member and governance I would
say
if we're doing the best practices that
align with what worksafe would expect us
to be doing then I I feel comfortable
I don't wanna be asked you know what's
your appetite for rest not when it comes
to this no way not in a million years so
I I I I just don't like the wording
being used
thanks for that we can play that on
advice
um obviously there are the risk the risk
type workshops and going on which we can
take that into and think that one
through
I am going to tempt to see if anybody's
prepared to move and second these
resolutions
um uh which is that uh we receive
that we note uh the residual risk is
outside
our stated risk tolerance
we note that the report
um
provided to the next meeting outlining
the steps to be taken
we note the summary of work undertaken
to date
and we note that the report will be
provided at the May 23 confirming the
alignment
of the Matrix and the assist between
health and safety and the risk framework
which indeed is a key point that we've
been talking about
yes snobby on movement an amendment to
three
because again it talks about council's
tolerance for risk and as other speakers
have said this morning we should not
have a tolerance to risk
so I would reword that to say something
along the lines
the latter part to remove the bit this
is um within council's tolerance so what
I'd be putting in there is that we want
to report to the next meeting about
um
about how we're going to bring our
health and safety
monitoring or governance within the
legislative requirements as opposed to
our tolerance which we see I think
that's hugely risky
so you're moving Amendment Lobby and
it's going to say if I've heard you
correctly to bring the health and safety
risk Within
the requirements of the health and
safety I wouldn't have the word risk
I'll just I'll just have the application
I think we have I
so can you tell sorry you've moved the
amendment I'm just trying to paraphrase
what I've heard from you can you tell me
what you want to bring health and safety
application
by Council to within the expectations of
the health and safety and Employment Act
I'll have a signal for that yes
wearing a legal hat I would caution you
against that wording of course if you
read that literally that says counselors
saying we're not complying with the act
and uh if you want to say that that's
fine but I would wearing my legal hat of
course you against that wording
it's not me that section three doesn't
say that at all what it says is note
that a report was to be provided to the
next meeting of this committee outlying
steps to be taken by this Council to
meet its obligations and and so it's not
saying that it's not saying that we're
not meeting it it's just saying they're
going to give us a report now
we're playing with words if we think
that we're meeting our obligations at
the moment I mean everybody around the
table's echoing that we're not
so let's let's be upfront and say that
we've got some staff coming that will
help us deliver our obligations under
the ACT
um
let's leave it there
do we have a segment of the Navy's
motion
Grant you do right it's any debate on
the motion
so the cautionless we've had from Andrew
is being careful about what we actually
say this is when words I think you're
arguing Andrew do count
which is reflecting
hello
um
slightly annoying in a serious time here
um uh um
when in reality
um
that sounds like we're saying we are not
complying with the act and that it's not
a circuit rule by by this I'm tempted
I'm I'm persuaded by your argument
actually uh Andrew
um I just wonder if we're wise
yeah
you've got two things here you've got
a tolerance level that we're aiming for
or we just meet
um the requirements
um that that's I thought they're targets
um I don't know you can't have like you
can't see anything one without the other
you you
um basically the report should be coming
to the next committee meeting that that
systems are in place to monitor
and ensure that that everything's best
practice
um
and basically so that we don't get
prosecuted
yeah yeah if we don't get wrong but the
use of council's tolerance so I mean you
could put in Brackets Council council's
tolerance means this
right I've got thank you rangi I've got
I've got advice for you Sam Aaron then
I've got Leslie and then Ross
um thank you chair I guess I just wanted
to seek some clarification because I I
guess I'm I'm hearing what council is
saying and I want to make sure that I
understand that direction correctly as a
GM for an area that does um hold a
significant portion of this risk
um
I I had asked Andrew to to push a bit of
a question around whether we really do
hold that adverse risk tolerance
um and I guess it's to to not be in
runghi's point around knobby made the
comment that
um you know your first step is whether
or not we can eliminate the risk then
can we put in place engineering controls
um if we can't then we would step
through around process procedure Etc
um but there's a number of instances in
what we run out at our treatment plants
our pump stations Etc where we could
take further steps to eliminate the risk
or to put in place engineering controls
which we haven't put in place due to the
significant cost associated with doing
that and so we have taken I guess a
balance around cost versus process
balancing that risk balancing that that
risk appetite
um
what I'm hearing is that Council doesn't
want to consider the risk appetite side
of it that we simply want to say we will
take all steps possible to eliminate
risk I want to be just clear is that the
correct direction that we are being
given
us for you to respond to yeah surely so
the first thing is I did not say the
first step was to remove the risk I said
the first step was to identify the risk
that's what the ACT requires then you
have two options two Pathways to go down
you remove the risk or you mitigate it
and the mitigation is quite clear it
does exactly what you've just said if if
you've got a piece of Machinery or give
you a good example
um
I tried to prosecute a company some
years ago many years a couple of decades
ago on a wool press
where a young man who was killed on the
wall press and the cost of of
safeguarding that given they had four of
these wall presses with their status was
about 300 000 per machine
um and and the courts agree that that
cost was an excessive amount to pay for
that risk that they needed to look at
other options around training and stuff
so whatever what you said after that
Aaron it's fine doesn't mean that yeah
you come to remove and that's the only
option removed is only the first step
you consider if it's not practical to do
it so if if you Safeguard the Machinery
in such a way that you can't actually
use up anything properly or interferes
the operations you can go down that
those other options but you've got to
catalog it while you've gone there you
just can't pop up when you've had a bad
exit and say oh well we didn't do
anything about it you've got to step
your way through that process otherwise
you have no defense thanks thanks knobby
I just let's just remember we are trying
to provide guidance to management here
we're not trying to do your job sure
okay I think that's some that's
important that we need to we need to
wear go back to uh the original comments
I think dare I said from you know I've
been I'll try to show words in your
mouth but actually we hit a monitor so
let's not try and prescribe because
that's actually Michael uh and his
team's role I've got
um Leslie then Ross thank you Leslie
so persuaded from a legal point of view
by what Andrew has said in relation to
the suggested amendment to
resolution three
um
and I would also like to point out if
you're going to remove any reference to
council's tolerance and resolution 3
then it would seem very strange not to
also propose altering resolution
Gray thank you Lucy that's great Ross I
was along the same lines that before we
voted I
recommend that Andrew consider the
wording which might incorporate
the cinnamon Expressway on the table now
but not
Unison to an issue later
unintended that's that requires some
time to do then maybe we do
move to the next paper and give Andrew a
little bit of time to reconsider just to
consider the words that might be
acceptable yes Darren
so if I can ask me a clerk if with your
proposed amendment
um
application by Council to within the
health and safety requirements in there
from what I I just heard you you
explaining you're accepting mitigation
as a part of that so it's not ensuring
that everything is is fully compliant
but in some cases as appropriate
mitigated it acts really clear so I'll
say it again or not being disrespectful
you have to first identify risks
second part is you then take one of two
paths one is to remove the risk
or alternative if that's not practical
and the word practical has been tested
in core
then you go down another pathway where
you start to look at things like
education
um safety equipment that might prevent
certain people getting into certain work
areas
wearing safety equipment and so on
there's a lot of stuff that flows down
there alternative path which Aaron is
alluded to
that's not the problem the problem is
when I read two and we'll need to amend
two as well chair I think is it sort of
implies here that we we've already got
some events occurring that are outside
our tolerance called the bottom line
with the actors you should not have
undertolerance for risks
you've got to identify and then deal
with them so it's a little bit like
saying well we've had let's say 10
incidents and tree trimming in the park
so that's beyond our tolerance so the
next question is if you had one or two
would that be within your tolerance and
risks are unique to themselves you can't
cluster them together
I guess is what I'm trying to say
it's not a defense or an area where you
get comfortable with
I like Ross as I did and obviously
injury but I'm wondering um before we
ask Andrew to do that then perhaps we
just let this this paper lie as I said I
think we could deal with the second
paper and come back to this sure I'm
wondering whether you would consider a
different wedding
which is that
um we bring the health
um sorry we the next meeting outlining
steps to improve health and safety
culture and practice
consistent without safety in the
workplace here well I guess the
amendment that I recommended had a
slightly different wording and that
referred to the end to within the health
and safety and Employment Act
requirements
obviously consistent with the health
yeah so what they've got up there at the
moment is health and safety requirements
well that's an open-ended statement we
need to reflect the app because the ACT
was very specific
it's one of the few areas that is very
specific in it it will override the
local government
we're indeed and legal stuff here it's a
good conversation to be honest yeah
um
we want to make certain we don't we we
record ourselves Faithfully with the
with their own Direction I tend to agree
that we can I'm happy with the
resolution gets rid of the word
tolerance I think that we can probably
deal with that discussion around risk
and how it relates to the requirements
of the health and safety act in our
discussion about this appetite I think
your amendment I think the word that
causes me concern is within because by
using within you're implying the
wherewithout
um and so improve to me I think deals
with the concern that I have
is that we are
within without at the moment anybody
sits around the table that thinks it wet
we've got a defensive position if we
have a serious accident in a dream world
we're exposed we should acknowledge that
we're exposed
six months for a year down the track
with the new staff we've got we might be
in a position to say
hand on heart we feel good about where
we're at
right let's see sorry
you earlier suggested that we leave this
on the table until we have dealt with
the next paper I don't think that's why
anywhere near the point at which
we can amend these resolutions with any
confidence until we've discussed the
next paper at this stage
thank you I'm inclined as I've said
before they go to do that because
actually the foundational paper about
our unease
around the corporate response and I'm
not blaming management I'm saying the
corporate response what we what we have
here isn't isn't that second paper so
I'm I'm going to propose unless I've got
um
significant objection and drag racing
this is a very good discussion
absolutely needed but I think we should
deal with the other paper first and then
we'll come back and look at all the
resolutions and see where we stand do I
have any objections to me um adjusting
my agenda in that way
I've lost sight of the these
recommendations or indeed your Amendment
might be but I think we should come back
to that once we've had a chance to look
at the more found what I consider the
more foundational paper that is the next
item on the agenda
right perhaps we could do that please
Andrew I suspect it's you to speak to
the progress
thank you Mr chair I mean my view on all
this is really quite simple you know for
all responsibilities and
accountabilities if you say you're going
to do something you monitor the people
do what they said they're going to do
and that's how they're judged you mean
in that that makes life pretty simple as
far as I'm concerned and that really is
all we're trying to highlight here that
um that's a key cultural piece I mean
everyone's got to buy into that as as
the method that we're going to hold
people accountable and once we buy into
that we can start to make changes as to
how everything happens because we've had
a lot of reports all those reports they
put another policy in place my immediate
responses are we following the policies
we currently have in place they might be
good they might be bad but unless we're
following them
and and that goes
hence why I drew out
this committee's role in a monitoring
role because that is part of the process
it's part of the culture and if we can't
have these sort of conversations and get
this sort of accountability and an
agreement and it's it's where as much as
you might not like it it's where we scap
a type it's the road we discuss what
that actually means and everyone gets an
understanding we can walk away and say
that's how we're going to behave because
we will all interpret the requirement as
far as practicable under the act in
different ways what we need to do is
agree what that means and the language
that most people use is risk appetite
because you will say as far as practical
and and to use the means earlier example
for small organization as far as
practical 300 000 might be too much
for us we're much bigger 300 000 went
well and truly within our capacity and
as far as practical so you've got to
you've got to have a discussion around
where those boundaries are going to be
and that's really what prompts Aaron's
question what do you mean because we're
making decisions on this all the time we
can't bring every decision in space up
to you and say
do I spend 500 000 do I spend and so
this this averse is actually tighter
than as far as practicable
to be honest and that's the way that
staff would interpret it as far as
practical is is an acceptance
that there's a financial limitation we
need to you we as a group need to decide
what do we really mean around that what
is as far as practical is it a million
dollars is it 500 000 is it two million
are any incidents and this is the
problem we have at the moment are any
incidents where people go to hospital
acceptable
and that will drive where we sit in this
space so this is this is trying to set
up a an agreement to an approach and you
can see that when you step through the
way we'll approach
incidents near misses whatever when they
occur and a lot of the time you'll find
the spotlights back on the organization
and what I'm flagging here and you need
to be full aware of all the time that
will mean we need to spend more money
and then this is the conversation that
I've been playing I mean we can't
necessarily
divorce the two but we need to we need
to be having the conversation
thank you uh for that Andrew has
anything else there's anything about the
particular papers I mean it introduces
the idea of just culture it's a response
to the original May 2022 reporters
anything else that you wanted to add to
that
I don't think so I'm happy to answer any
questions on why I've chosen that why I
think that works you can certainly set
that out in the table to a certain
extent
um but it's it's a concept that
I think will address the issues that
we've got there's any comment you could
add about the pr law advice so we've
talked about you know you've mentioned
the monitoring there's a fair bit of
advice there that actually might be
useful for you to clarify if there's any
what you want to make it's really just
drawing out that distinction and I think
to put a blunt Wing I mean I I think the
the
comments around the monitoring are on
the money
what we need to all do is hold ourselves
to those comments in different
circumstances because we don't always
um but I think if we accept that then
that's good and and then that means
everyone can get on with their job and
have the accountability and this is the
key thing until we agree responsibility
we can't allocate accountability
and that that's the key part of people
recognizing their role because until you
the way I always describe it to people
is if you've got two masters or two
people are doing something then I can't
turn around and say who do I hold
accountable when it doesn't work and so
we've got to be make sure we are clear
on that
um and I and I think what I'm hearing
today is we are
um and so that's good
thanks Andrew you're right um Steve
you're obviously come to the front as
well as uh and and obviously you've
spoken to us before and and I take it
your lead around some of this is
anything you'd like to add before I um
start with Nobby uh yeah thank you Mr
chair look I I probably here just to
talk a little bit more about the save
plus report and and the work that hasn't
been undertaken over since about June of
last year
around reflecting on what that report's
telling us it's an organization and I
think to a degree the conversation today
has flagged around our level of maturity
as an organization and when we all
recognize it needs to improve
uh I think one of the questions earlier
from councilor Germany was around
um we're not waiting for May this year
to have an action plan we've we've had
an action plan since about June July of
last year and we've progressively been
working on making sure that we've
responded to this report
by some terms of the way in which we
communicate to our staff in which we
make it easier to communicate around
what our risks are but also getting our
organization at a staffing level uh
right size for the for the challenge in
front of us around managing health and
safety and wellbeing at our workplace
so we have we did undertake to go away
and talk to all the staff engaged
directly in this report uh we've done
that
um we've asked them to have a
contribution uh they've given us
feedback we've also then talked to all
the senior managers and the organization
shared the report with them and the
reports been made available to every
staff member and is now available to the
community
thanks Steve appreciate that right thank
you for two quite fundamental
reports attached to the paper and the
reflection about a need to mature right
I'll be your first nothing of running
and then grab
um
I guess several things
I'm not sure I'm comfortable if we're
having a
I guess an honesty session here around
Andrew's comments about
um
where is their risk appetite and our
risk maturity and that if we go down the
path of having as far as practical type
discussions that will cost us lots of
money that's not been my experience
most health and safety is not driven by
physical cost it's driven by practice
the way people operate and where the way
they get complacent around what an
outsider might look at as a significant
risk but they've been there for 20 years
and they're familiar with it so I'm not
sure that's the case and I guess in
Steve's when he made mention of the need
to improve our risk of maturity and I'm
not sure actually what that means the
bottom line for me as I've said before
is that we should not be using words
like Risk appetite that act is quite
clear there is zero tolerance to any
risk it's what you do with those risks
after you've identified them is where
the organization needs to go because if
you start talking risk appetite
or anything around that it implies that
you have I guess an already
predetermined level that you'll accept
some risks as not being dealt with under
the ACT you're just saying yeah we've
got some of those risks and we've got an
appetite to just leave them sitting
there because they may cost us some time
or energy or money
and I think that will come back to buy
this one day
thank you baby great
yeah oh sorry sorry Grant I actually
said yeah
look
um first one straight off the block is
um in the purpose and summary of this
report and that is risk maturity like I
just Googled risk maturity to find out
what what it actually means because it's
it's a cool sounding phrase
um and everyone knows what mature is but
when you apply it to risk maturity it
clearly points out that the more mature
you are with risk is that you
ignore the noise and you focus on key
elements and you deal with them
and and very effective manageable ways
and that overcomes any
extreme costs things like 300 000. that
being mature
doing something 300 000 would not be
immature
action because it's obviously that's you
haven't from what I'm reading about
maturity that's not the way you deal
with things
and so the other thing is moving on to
it says this committee has a fundamental
role in a addressing risk maturity now
when we go to the pr law advice
it it states that um
that through working with the chief
executive elected members can monitor
and review the icc's performance
on its health and safety obligations now
what do we what's this committee for are
we supposed to be I'm just trying to
work this one out
it's telling us to go through my call
but as Michael's sort of delegating
that role to this committee or how does
this work I mean it clearly says that we
should be going through Michael without
concerns
but what does this committee
how does it second someone explain that
to me
because I'm not quite getting it then if
if that if we've got concerns with
health and safety we should go to
Michael
but obviously
we're writing amongst it now look I I
I'm kind of can we just be clear here
risk maturity is pretty simple
and I look at I look at the report the
safe plus report does it look like a
mature organization to you that's
managing risk okay does it no it doesn't
no
and and hence what I think is a very
good report for management
we're taking this as Baseline I take it
that's what you're doing here Steve
you're saying look we're basically
accepting the report I haven't seen any
since our rejection of it
I think I would like to reflect in it
that also reflects some doing really
good work and I'm conscious we have
staff from the organization who are
clearly doing good work
the challenge of the report is that that
is actually
um not consistent across the
organization
and there are challenges which I'm
hearing as being grouped up by Senior
Management and ultimately by our chief
executive who we have acknowledged
has under the act and in the local
government context
the responsibility and the liability
which he well knows about
our monitoring role
is I think clearly articulated in the pr
law advice and Andrew's been saying do
your job and he's put it to us in effect
with the last report this is the same
report you've seen many times before and
you had really done your job
so I think monitoring just has the
common sense weird
so I think I think can I be honest we
need to deal with the real stuff and not
the semantics
this is a call to Arms
and Grant some of your stuff has been
we'd like to see what the plan is in
that quarter arms
and you're saying Steve you've had the
report you're starting to do things and
in my in May
we will find what is that full roadmap
which is saying not only do we not only
are you doing stuff now
but in reality you will give us
don't want to use the word comprehensive
but I do want to use the word
comprehensive Steve what is the plan
going forward which must
lead to
I presume at some point a better safe
plus report
and it goes back to your point knobby
that we need external verification we
clearly do external external
verification as said we're behind the
eight ball or at least we're not where
we ideally should be
we need external verification relatively
soon
that we're on the right track
okay I you know I think there's a lot of
common sense behind what we're doing
here the paper talks about that process
in part through the idea of just culture
um so I think we just need to treat this
on good faith that this is where it's at
Michael is there any comment you'd like
to make before I go back to I think um
Grant is next
yeah throw yourself to you I'd just like
to add um the component we always say
getting the external advice and support
going forward or review I would suggest
that give us give us a a reasonable time
frame to actually do some remedial Works
in relation to it we we are taking this
on board and taking it on the chin and
actually moving forward that we we would
like and I would like
um a review at a later date but it's
it's not now
we need to actually get some actions in
place and get some runs on the ladder
I'd suggest that that could be something
within
um probably a six-month time frame that
you would look at that thank you and I'd
like to I'd like to Grant to have this
question that's okay and then I can come
back back to you yes great yes I've got
a few so firstly with the
um what seemed to be a question from the
officer around choose workplace safety
or cost
um and I agree with um the mere's
comment you know that's just simply too
arbitrary
so you know there's a bigger process
that need to be looked around
um it's not just simply about oh well
we've identified a risk and then you
decide whether you want to spend the
money or not so that's the approach that
officers are taking I think needs to be
looked at that's just the comment
you know health and safety is simple
it's about getting people home safe
and and that's the simplest mindset that
every single person on their contracts
or works with ICC needs to have every
day
and if they have that mindset they will
probably more likely than not get home
safe every day
and that's the responsibility everyone
through the organization needs to have
what
concerns me and this report's written in
May 21 and we're now on
April well March 23 you know I can't get
confidence
that what are the three or four things
that are happening on site every day to
ensure that we are
making sure air organization is safe and
I would expect if you can't do it now by
may you should better come to this
committee and say Here's the three or
four thing actions that are happening
every single day and to give you some
examples
and other organizations within the city
there's there's Take Five
which you'll probably be aware of where
staff stop and take five when they're
dealing with a piece of equipment and go
through a process there's there's
operational things which contractors to
this council do where they have videos
that when they have the equipment
they're operating before they have to
use that equipment they have to show
that they've watched the video to make
sure they are safe
now that happens with contractors that
contractor this Council
so you know what I want to see is the
three or four things that this the
officers have enacted between now and
may that
can give me some assurance that we are
getting people home safe or getting the
best opportunity for our people to get
home safe be their contractors be their
staff every day
and I think that's what this coming in
is the facts I'm very very clearly just
change the culture which is obviously
transitioning but to my mind it's not
transitioning fast enough and it needs
to be action not reports and graphs and
words
I'd like I'd like to reflect on that
Grant if I could and I'm one I think we
need to be careful here
we are being we are being and I want us
to respect the advice that's that that
staff are giving us and we we and I
don't want to see tackling of Staff in
this committee where they're raising the
issue and the issue is about health and
safety culture
I think we need we we need to recognize
that health and safety
action is actually happening
you know and and even the safe plus
report says that
and indeed we've already had
descriptions today
about other actions that are being taken
particularly as the senior management
team group up in for which I'm grateful
for
I think we've also uh and your points
are being well made and I don't disagree
with them I'm Keen to know what the
action is and I think we have agreed
um that well we haven't agreed actually
we've got to get back to the resolution
but that may 2023 is go you know our
meeting is going to be what is the
action plan
you've had assurances today from from
staff that there are other you know
there is an ongoing line of action I
think you were explaining from June last
year by the way it was a May 2022 report
not 21.
um so so clearly there are things that
are happening so it's 21 it's written
online I thought it was 22. what's got
21.
22 months old sorry my mistake right
um so so I mean I think the point I'm
trying to make here is there is not an
absence
of health and safety in the organization
at the moment it's a clear message
we can and must do better
so at this stage short of a some form of
interim paper we're asking uh staff to
come back what's the roadmap for our
next meeting in May
right so I've got my view think of your
way to patiently then I have got Leslie
then I've got ring
so a couple of issues um for Michael's
uh peace of mind when I was referring to
external verification I wasn't talking
about outside the organization I'm
talking about outside the workplace so
if you've got a workshop I don't know in
the Parks you'd have somebody that goes
in with some background knowledge to
have a look that doesn't actually work
there and obviously ideal people will be
the people you're recruiting at the
moment for health and safety that that
wider sweep Again by some outside
organization is way down the track
um
clearly we have to sit
within the next three or four months
five months now maybe some new kpis for
the chief executive that's part of the
deal with everyone I would expect that
compliance with
health and safety under the ACT would be
one of those key areas that we want to
see some development in
um and just one reflection on the pr law
paper which I think is very good
um but it does leave a little bit of a
confusion around what we're required to
under the health and safety unemployment
act and there are obligations under the
Local Government Act to be a good
employer and provide a safe environment
um and so to give you a steer on that
back when we closed the museum
um
ages ago we've got some specific advice
I'm going to say we not Council around
um with the health and safety of
employees at the museum with that act
overrode the building
Act and the building code and the advice
we got back which is what I said before
was that if you have a specific act or
code made within an act it overrides
more generic
statements elsewhere so what that means
is our need to
adhere to the health so safety
Employment Act which sits with the chief
executive under the pcbu so that's a
person conducting a business unit we are
exempt from that
so the obligation is for the senior
staff to chief executive and his
executive team to deliver that we've
just got to make sure they deliver
where in other settings other than us if
we were out in the private sector we
would be accountable as more directors
so that's quite a significant difference
and what it says is while we all want to
be good employers and we as Governors
have obligations under the Local
Government Act we don't have obligations
legally
under the health and safety Employment
Act other than we have the Local
Government Act saying that we must be
good employers and ensure that happens
but we don't actually have the legal
operation that sits with the chief
executive it's quite subtle but it's
important
and just reinforce what you're saying
this fix that we need to have is not a
quick fix changing the culture and
bringing the new stuff in will probably
take a year to better at least oh yes
I've Michael put six months on it I you
know I think we you know we clearly the
road map should have action many actions
that will be achieved within the year
but I would I would have thought we need
at least another year before an
accidental review and I distinctly made
an external review there by the way I
take your point about uh actions right
Leslie please
afflictions on this paper and the topic
we are discussing
I'd just like to point out that we're
we're at the point where I don't see
there's any disagreement at all with the
recommendations that are before us the
adoption of the just culture approach
seems to be something that everybody is
in tune
it seems a sensible way to move forward
and I'd like at this point to suggest I
am very happy to move these
recommendations all six of them in a
block thank you Leslie do we have a
seconder for that
you just thank you Ross appreciate that
okay
so we have a motion but running you also
would like to talk yeah look mine's a
just uh reading the safe plus report
and paragraph four was quite
straightforward my question is
considering that elected members make up
80 percent of the risk and insurance
committee
why councilors were not interviewed as
part of this assessment
what the logic of elt was for that not
happening
the season here as per the request of
elt
um I'm just wondering why because I mean
obviously the elected members we form
part of this we get emails asking to go
out and visit certain sites to to to
monitor health and safety and I just
wonder why
um there was deliberate direction for us
to not be involved
in this paragraph four of people is
there a short answer Andrew I I'm sure
the person who is employed and engaged
at the time no longer works here I
really mean it and I'm not saying clear
in that context the the health and
safety officer at the time who was
instrumental in this I've got no idea
what the thinking was there sorry
on Earth says elt I I now wanted yeah
yeah you're not saying I'm just saying I
don't know unless someone else has any I
don't have any um obviously the Genesis
of the reporters is a reasonable way
back now and and again Grant my
apologies that I thought it was May 22
not May 21 I know you're quite right it
says that
um it's quite a while ago rangi I see
any value in trying to work out yes I I
can probably notionally agree or I
logically agree that it would be useful
in a future assessment Council has given
a monitoring role would be included as
well
I think the reality of it is I go back
to let's take the report as a whole it's
a call to Arms management degree with it
there's enough in there for us to say
we've got some serious matters to
address uh whistle without a complete
population of an interview with which
obviously is excluding counselors so I
think we move on I have a recommendation
I'm of the mind that I'd like to put it
you've got a final comment knobby yeah
I'm just gonna move an amendment in 5A
uh to exclude the words including risk
including against risk appetite which is
part of the discussion we had before
that our role as a committee is just to
monitor the risks
um and to look to uh proving the risk
maturity don't have any problems with
sex but again that means that we're
doing some gatekeeping around what we
believe is success is okay by an
appetite there should be no appetite for
eign
because that's what that's what
committee's all about before I um before
we make this formal Leslie are you happy
with that or would you like to put a get
that done through a proper amendment I
think it should be done through a proper
Amendment okay thank you so I have a
move I have I have a move from um
Lobby do I have a signal please
put the amendment all those in favor
please say aye
those against
um just just check I probably have a
majority of hands here can I just sorry
voices can I just ask
who voted for could you put your hands
please
Darren Grant knobby
so that's one two three four five this
is one
two three so the motion
is passed it becomes a substantive
motion which reduces or takes out the
including against risk appetite
is there any further discussion on the
motion
I'll put the motion
all those in favor please say
aye aye those against
carry thank you very much
I read somewhere else today Steve that
they like is a good disinfectant
and thank you for bringing this report
and I appreciate that we have seen this
in public rather than public excluded
because if there's one thing that
collectively and from a combined sense
will drive action is US acknowledging
and I I will be very keen and we're
obviously all very keen to see what
comes back in May
um and I would want to reflect that I
hope there's a committee along with
management we are strongly unified and
clearly what has been your
recommendation and ultimately what we
have adopted
which is actually we want culturally and
in reality to improve our health and
safety in this organization that's great
and I now move us back to the last paper
please where we have some outstanding
recommendations yes not just a just a
small point on that last paper that we
adopted
the health and safety progress report it
refers to Michael as being the acting
chief executive that's no longer the
case
chief executive she's saying in the in
the uh it's just in the top part we've
had it in some other reports as well
seventh for my coordinating
apologize for
right so we need to go back to the um
the recommendations
um on uh
on the prior paper
it was important that we don't where
does what does that show us that shows
that actually we aren't we we
collectively with the advice of
management know that we have to improve
we have advice
um from management under two and I want
to be carefully with my wedding here
that the results are not acceptable
okay and an effect under three five
we are going to get a report on
I think Steve current actions because
clearly you're taking current actions
and actually what is the roadmap
development
that is effectively what's going to
happen
um by the way I'd also like to think
that perhaps that you might want to
think about the nature of what this
report looks like because I don't think
from the comments that it's uh that's
necessary the report we should always
have for monitoring Ross you've
mentioned well-being for instance and
Andrew you said you'll look at that so
there's a bit of that into into actually
how we can also monitor with greater
maturity too
so I've I've set what's happening in
generality but we're struggling with the
words here
and I want us to focus if I can
immediately on the generality and and
actually get a resolution going here
um uh I'm just wondering I'm looking for
leadership from the team or the
committee how you'd like to take a photo
even Michael you got to be a yes
Mr chair I think it would be helpful if
your alternative words for
recommendation three were also on the
board
is a is um
any other thoughts so I mean look the
bottom line that's itching us is is and
I think this this is actually a
discussion we we talk about developing
risk maturity that we're struggling with
collectively
is this idea of risk and risk tolerance
okay and we and it was a thing that was
noted when we did the review of this
committee last year was actually we
aren't
don't have
a confirmed set of strategic risks
and indeed how we think about tolerance
and I know Andrew you're in the process
of working with us as far as that's
concerned so we're actually we are
actually struggling to weave it with
this word and whether it fits within the
health and safety uh um uh legislation
and I'm not exactly certain that we
should buy ourselves into a fight today
on those words yes wrong
when you talk about Council
and council's tolerance yes is Council
being referred to elected members yes
specifically specifically okay then this
is very important that we get this right
because I'm not saying we can get it
right today that's my point that's
that's my point rongi is that actually
we are ourselves in a bit of a journey
with Andrew around risk and risk
tolerance and risk management
and and we're getting ourselves hooked
up in this well the reason I asked that
is is there a potential out in the
management
to say well this was council's tolerance
okay is that there's no wriggle I'm just
trying to get around the wording and
where management set and their own
tolerance
is there a management tolerance or is it
purely tolerance from elected members I
think what you're you're hearing from
Andrew
is that the is that in the generality so
I'm talking risk management generally
not just health and safety it starts
from the top from elected members
right okay okay
so two's actually correct isn't it
because it's outside your tolerance
isn't it I mean what I've been hearing
is today that actually yeah uh one is
too many so in fact it is outside the
tolerance it's correct that that is a
correct statement there
so in light of that I'd move two further
amendments I'd totally take out
um number two
because that talks about us having a
tolerance for some degree of risk and
the ACT does not require that it
requires that risks are risks
and down and five we also need some
thought about whether we need five as
well
because that's talking again the Gap
about a risk Matrix and how the
framework sits within that and again the
ACT is quite clear
you have to identify all this you don't
have an ability as an organization to
have a tolerance for not doing that work
and look I mean I don't want to get into
some ethics here either I think what
Mike was raised in his first week of uh
being the leader of our city is great
around health and safety we've prob
we've got staff coming now which is
great it gives us pathway forward that
will take time to bid in but I think
it's really important that we don't give
a message going forward that we have
some sort of Tolerance
for cutting aside breast
I think it's hugely dangerous once again
um can I just respond to that one I can
handle all the five going because I
think that threat button the more
broadly the the what's Trot we're trying
to have under three and what we've
agreed under the previous one of the
report that's coming through about about
the road map
two's important because it's saying
we're not happy with the situation at
the moment and that's let's face it
Management's recommendation to us yeah
that we have some form of expression
that the results
are not the results that we consider
acceptable
that's what I was trying to raise in
terms of the generality and getting away
and out of the area that we're exploring
around risk risk management and risk
tolerance
but I think Andrew and I and I'm looking
down your end of the table Andrew is
that you're wanting us to acknowledge
that your recommendation that this is
not an acceptable position if it's
management to you and I'd like to
suggest that we need to record to as
being our position Nobby rather than
just saying we don't need to pass this
resolution yeah yeah well I guess in
response to that two two doesn't say
what you just said
using risk management yeah terminology
well again the issue for me is if if
that was word in such a way that said
note that the current
um
risks that we face as an organization
are outside the expectations of the ACT
I could live with that but once you
start introducing council's stated risk
tolerance that says that we have another
layer that's okay for us to be feeling
comfortable and there is no layering in
this issue yeah Uncle Michael sorry yeah
thank you through yourself chair
um I think
there is a little bit of cloudiness in
relation to compliance with the ACT
going on and risk tolerance
um which are
not mutually exclusive in in in the fact
that compliance with the actors
as a requirement from that perspective
the tolerance comes when you look within
the ACT
and you go look at risk mitigation or
risk removal
and that's where you have to look in at
the tolerance levels we're still
applying the ACT it's to what degree do
you want the ACT to be applied in
relation to how far do you go down do
you completely remove all risk or do you
have a tolerance and you put mitigation
measures in for that risk but it still
remains in some capacity
because if you go down the ladder of
remove all risk
which would be the very risk adverse
removal of all risks would mean
potentially not doing a lot of services
because we by the nature of the sheer
nature of local government a lot of the
services we provide and in the
construction we have risk associated but
our aim is to put in mitigation measures
to reduce that to the last level
depending on the tolerance level and our
tolerance level is low so therefore we
have to put in the mitigation measures
to lower that down
still within the ACT we are complying
with the egg it's just what is that
level you want us to go remove or
mitigate
so it just doesn't respond to that chair
um again
um we've got the car before the horse
bottom line is we have to identify the
risk first we've got a nowhere risker
that's that's where our big hurt is at
the moment we don't know where they are
and if we have an incident or serious
instant or an accident the Lord forbid a
fatal accident around an air where we
don't I've pre-identified the risk we
have huge exposure
and so if what you do with the risk is
what Michael was just saying and to me
that's not a risk tolerance it's just
the way that you behave to a risk
index that the ACT prescribes that you
step through the process
right yeah I I think there's a bit of
sort of cross privacy so I agree with
you cheers like two to me talks through
the overall governance of her
organization
right so we will have a tolerance and
then when we're specifically talking
about the ACT we you can't have
tolerance in this so I think you know
both arguments are right that it's just
assembly you're complying and you're not
but from a statement to I read it as
steeping right back overseeing a whole
governance thing where does this sit
within their risk management tolerance
governance process flag that it it's
outside so therefore then dig deeply
into okay how we're managing that risk
accepting that we're not going to have
any tolerance to
um risk in our business we want to make
sure we get a removal manage or minimize
so that's it how I sit so I I support
what you're saying is what you know I
think I've interpreted that the way
you've
you might work out what words would go
with too for you right that might be
helpful for them for the meeting so we
can try and get a resolution through yes
running so just going back to
um a maturity risk maturity so I'm going
to assume then from what Michael was
saying an organization with high
maturity would easily deal with those
conundrums that
present with extreme cost to fix
something or avoid something the
maturity you have the ability to be able
to work and navigate your way through
those things quite easily because you
are mature
you know that's what I'm trying to
understand with this risk maturity it
puts you at a level that that you seem
to be able to overcome
uh these these black and white these
really dramatic problems is that true
broadly I would agree but running
honestly that's the prior paper
we're trying to deal with the current
paper which is the current results and
actually how we get a resolution on the
board I agree with you and I think and I
think in our in our risk workshops
Andrew there's a lot more to talk about
around what is risk maturity
but I I have argued strong and I see it
fits in here no it doesn't this is
actually about we've got a report on it
on existing
um uh um events and occurrences
um that reflect health and safety in the
organization as it stands and we're
trying to say in two that it is beyond
our comfort zone whatever is a good word
for that now it can't be risk tolerance
it's not going to get it it's going to
get through it I'm just looking for the
right descriptor
because I think it's important because
management are telling us we're telling
ourselves this isn't where we want to be
what's that word that we use we can't
use risk tolerance what is it we're
uncomfortable we don't accept it what's
that what's the what's the word I just
think a simple word yes well I think the
independence
the independent report that we got
clearly shows that we're not meeting our
obligations and we should just be
upfront about that
we've got some work to do and it's okay
to yeah to clear that appreciate that
and and but I think I'm going back to
some extent that's the problem this is
just not the current results so I'm just
trying to look for that descriptor yeah
Andrew looks like you're about to break
in the song okay
Michael probably kick me from Raising
but but I think and why that wording
around breaching Act is very important
because as we all agree who's liable if
we're breaking the ACT yeah
and so I don't think it is in
any way fair for you as governors
to make a statement in a resolution that
says my senior staff are liable under
the ACT
yeah
this is go back to your argument about
about being careful about the legal
organization we place now you're being
quite definite to Mike as far as yep
well that's what the ACT actually says
PCU PC a great bu actually says
in relation to this organization the
buck does stop with Michael
so it's not unfair to say that it's an
obligation that we have with him as
chief executive
um it's clear that then puts where the
accountability to ensure that we are
complying with exercise our job as
employers of the TV executive this was
for sure through kpis that he delivers
on it
right grant so if you add
um the council stated governance risk
tolerance because that
help point the reader to the fact that
you know the separate the fact that
we're looking at two around the overall
where does it sit within our overall
governance risk management of our
organization
sorry again
to interrupt here I'd take it back to
the core evidence that's in the paper
and say uh note that the issues near
misses and other events identified in
the report are not acceptable for
counseling yep I like that idea Andrew
thank you
um I wonder if we could capture the
malavika
thank you so appreciate your help that's
right it's not acceptable and I I think
Grant I think Grant we need in I mean
look I I don't want to be cute but
this is a strong advice from management
and and uh which will include Michael
that's where we all feel I think we need
to express in reasonably simple terms
because we know we've got some more work
to do around around actually our use of
words our relationship with the it's
part of our developing maturity
if I missed Darren did you want to say
something I'm sorry I just conscious
that I I have I missed anybody out
right so let's deal with one we're okay
two so um I'm gonna go with I'm gonna go
with Andrew's wedding unless anybody
really wants to have a have another
Clerk of this I hope not you just said
note the incident reporting for
employees and third-party contractors
recorded in the report is not acceptable
is not acceptable thank you that's cool
that's reflecting that we're pretty
unhappy is is management I want to
stress that as is management we're both
we're collectively
right
so uh three uh sorry um can I just go
can I come back to three last
um so four I think was relatively about
to say innocuous that's a bad word was
relatively okay we note the summary of
work undertaken to date
okay
um five
um
uh the question here was is three an
effect
look at that right
I I don't need five chair that all
that's pointing out is that when we look
at risk we have a risk framework which
includes health and safety which uses
certain terminology we also have a
toolkit for health and safety which has
a risk framework in it which uses
different terminology I can fix that
with or without the resolution so
without the resolution
although actually it's quite important
to do that to get the alignment right
but I take your point I don't think we
directly need that that's the level of
work below which is Again part of that
maturity path so we delete five let's
find it leaves us with three
and Leslie you have asked me to put up
the alternate which was uh my suggested
wedding
which to be honest is more General
knobby but I don't actually see I offer
as a way of getting round
um what it's actually and I'm I am
putting the putting it strongly as we
try and work through and gain that
greater understanding which clearly you
have a greater understanding of than us
around this issue of the placement of
um
culture and practices I've got there
within our with our environment and we
need we need the report which is a
critical thing we need to report which I
think is a point you make I'm quite
happy with the old tournament you're
happy with the alternate absolutely
thank you
um well actually to be honest I think we
I have a actually a an amendment moved
by you Nobby and you're saying you're
happy yeah um I think I had a second
before that was that too rangi that was
me oh sorry it's you grant are you happy
with that yeah
radio so why don't I think seeing that
we might have a solution here
um put that Amendment so I'll put it all
those in favor please say I I those
against
Carrie so if it comes a substantive part
of the motion so just to reflect once
those are saying two is there in the red
we've got work to do three Sears we're
going to report on that four series we
know the summary from within the
recorded
now did I have it sorry to be honest
because I have an original mover and
signal I don't think I did do I have a
mover for this please thank you grant
secondary thank you Nobby appreciate
that
any discussion on the motion not me
all those in favor please say aye
aye close against it's Carrie thank you
very much
again I just want to reflect here
um members thank you for taking us
through what is a reasonably difficult
discussion because we don't like
negative results
but I want to reflect here that what we
have agreed to is combined action
around health and safety
and we all collectively have a lot to
learn whether it's whether it's
um Michael with a zlt or whether it's us
with a committee and I do want to
reflect one thing we need to reflect
this ultimately to war council because
we are dealing with a matter that
actually all councils should be where
have you scrub yeah just on that
um
would it be worthwhile that um Michael
also brings to the May meeting
um
you know a paper around
are there any additional supports we can
offer to management
whatever they may be training you know
to ensure that we're supporting the
executive
to get across the line yeah you know
because it's I agree it's governance and
then it's Senior Management it's all the
way down and all about but you know I
suppose what we need to be assured is
that Michael has all the resources given
it to his ultimate responsibility to be
able to go forward in the way we want
them to so it'll be good to get
something back from Michael on that if
it's sooner than that then fine but yeah
I just think that would be important for
us to receive
I'm sure we can add that into that
report yeah thank you
from the idea grant that actually as we
go down that road to mature we've got a
couple of good positions being filled
which is bringing strengths to the
position but as we do go through
maturity we may find we have to to
continually readdress the resourcing
um issue
um as we go through thank you for that
right don't go away Andrew and welcome
back Peter uh can you sell your points
sorry as zero
all right you got a point oh yeah like
it was just before finishing off
um obviously we've talked in our in our
risk assessments
um about staff employees contractors
where do we sit with obviously the
public
um now just mindful of what happened in
Gore
um with the pond and and obviously uh
the theater our facilities or what we do
where do we how far reaching
I mean obviously we've got writing
networks we've got all sorts of networks
um
stormwater stuff like that now how is
this what we're talking about as well
when we're looking at this risk maturity
there's a bar reach out into everything
we provide
and do
um
yes right users of our facilities
clearly come within the perfect whatever
responsible yeah no just sort of they've
flown under the radar all about them and
again it's it's a lot of the incidents
and their misses you're talking about to
come from users of the facility so
that's yeah that's good I just needed to
ask Bobby that was consistent with what
you were going to say uh you're just a
little bit um part of the ACT talks
about um legal obligation so people are
legally entitled to be on you on your
premises so if somebody breaks into one
of their pump houses that doesn't create
us a risk but if somebody is there
mowing the Lawns which is an example
that's in the safety report then we do
have an obligation to them thank you
appreciate that
Andrew Peter we could have a selling
points on your report please uh not from
me but Andrew may want to make support
I suppose again the key Point here is
trying to drag it back to uh in this
case what might be an easier topic
around our tolerance
um so we get we get and it's the same
with the um uh the earlier Audits and
stuff it's important that when we review
uh and we might need to go back through
this but when we look at controls and
mitigations that we have in place it's
important that when we do these reviews
we look at them around their
effectiveness because that's what we're
really seeing it's not that we don't
have controls in place they just might
not be effective and that's the piece
that we really need to unpick and
understand why and so again looking at
the the reporting here around the public
records Act
back to the Local Government Act back to
the workplace health and safety act we
have an overriding tolerance which is
very low for breach of the ACT
now this on the Facebook is saying we're
not necessarily there but we don't
really I didn't have time and we don't
really understand or address how far shy
there are we and is that a concern and
how quickly therefore do you want us to
respond to these concerns to make sure
that we are compliant with what is
orbited important but probably not a an
act that's going to cause you a lot of
grief in the short term but that doesn't
mean that we shouldn't remedy any issues
that are identified and that's where I
want to keep moving the conversation
rather than getting the information what
does that mean what do you want us to do
about it what are we saying we should do
about it and taking that forward in the
future and that's really where the risk
management conversation should be
occurring
and I I know
the recommendations are particularly
under public records act at this stage
you're asking us to note the current
and the steps that have been taken to
reduce
levels of non-compliance in terms of
this meeting but obviously there's a
broader broader discussion around
um uh uh risk um tolerance and appetite
at a different time and touching on
accounts fighting just points risk
maturity I mean
do we actually even know every act and
whether or not we're complying with it
now we're complying with it and controls
are in place
you know it's an internal problem for
local government yeah yeah exactly
thank you you're welcome questions for
for Andrew on this report
all right you obviously want one top and
I don't know I was about to move on
I waited I waited too long and I'll be
sorry I've used a bit of tongue-in-cheek
mate maybe we have a we have a risk
appetite to not comply with this piece
of the leader so if you do have a risk
appetite do you I wondered if it might
be might be the case
look thank you for that um look it's
really useful in fact I to be honest um
I probably had some empathy with your
thoughts buddy but actually Andrew thank
you because it is actually
one of those Apes that teens that come
back and bite you if you do not have
appropriate approaches so I'm just
grateful we've got this update and I'm
comfortable with the direction you're
taking this in can I move to the
recommendations please which is that we
received the report we note the steps
around the public records act and we
know that the program of work will be
provided to improve the monitoring of
council's non-financial risk so that's a
really important part as well
I'll move that from cheers please thank
you Leslie emotional those in favor
please say aye all right
thank you very much
right I think we are at the end of the
open Agenda which moves us into the
the resolution
um to move into public excluded we have
a number of matters which if you're on
page three agendas is a through e
and it follows with the reasons why I
will move from the chair that we move
into public excluded thank you Darren is
there any debate on the motion yes
there's one minor thing I noticed that
our live stream has been frozen for
quite some time
listening
thank you appreciate that I sound like
I'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye all right those against
us carry
and I suggest